hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're on the new Gears of War 5
technical test this was released I
believe just today and if you have the
game past and you can get this for free
and if also if you've pre-ordered you
could get this too but seeing as the
queue times are super super long and not
many people been able to play due to
server issues I actually still have yet
to been able to play one full game yet
so I've basically just been running
bootcamp and looking at the
customization I'm gonna be showing off
all the executions that come with every
weapon this is of course when you down
an opponent you hold the B button you
can execute them and there's different
ones per weapon that you use but there
will be a default one per character
there's going to be a lot more when they
release it in the little supply drops
they have but this is just the default
green one so if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new and I'll show you the
video right now take care guys
[Applause]
[Music]